Il parait que t’aimes bien ça toi.
Euh oui, pourquoi ?
C’est pour une expérience.
Allez, continue.
Nan, c’est gentil…
Ça, c’est le pétrole et toi, t’es la demande.
Alors tu bois.
- Nan, mais j’ai pas…
- Qu’est-ce que vous faites là ?
On dirait bien que la demande a augmenté.
Pendant la pandémie de la covid19 la consommation de pétrole a rapidement chuté.
Les routes et les rues étaient désertes, les voitures garées, les usines se sont arrêtées.
Mais l’extraction de pétrole ça ne s’arrête pas si facilement.
En avril 2020 ça déborde,
le prix du pétrole chute, il passe sous le 0.
Tout le monde cherche désespérément à le stocker en attendant que la demande remonte.
Parce que la demande va remonter, depuis plus de 100 ans, chaque année ou presque,
l’extraction et la consommation de pétrole augmente.
Tu sais que le pétrole, c’est une soupe de planctons pourris ?
On peut voir les océans comme un smoothie de matière organique riche en planctons.
En mourant, le plancton tombe au fond de l’océan et se retrouve piégé dans les sédiments.
Il est ensuite décomposé par des microbes, il pourrit.
Dans certaines conditions, ça peut donner du kérogène.
C’est l’étape 1 du pétrole.
On s’en fout.
Et si ces roches sont enfouies en profondeur grâce aux joies de la tectonique des plaques,
ça chauffe le kérogène et ça lui pyrolyse la face.
Comme si vous mettiez des animaux morts et décomposés dans votre four.
Nan, ne faites pas ça, c’est une suggestion de présentation.
Et, paf, ça fait des hydrocarbures. Du pétrole et du gaz naturel.
Alors tout ça, ce n’est pas instantané évidemment, ça prend au moins plusieurs dizaines de millions d’années.
En tout cas, la plupart du pétrole qu’on extrait aujourd’hui s’est formé de 60 à 250 millions d’années pendant l’ère mésozoïque.
Mézosenfou !
Parce qu’à ce moment-là, le climat était relativement tropical, la vie était riche et prospère. Et comme il y avait beaucoup de vies, il y avait aussi beaucoup de morts.
Et probablement qu’en ce moment, quelque part sur Terre, du pétrole est en train de se former.
Et sera peut-être extrait par nos arrière,
arrière, arrière, arrière, arrière, arrière, arrière petits-enfants.
Donc finalement, le pétrole est une énergie renouvelable à l’échelle des temps géologiques.
Mais à notre échelle à nous, humains, c’est une ressource finie.
Le fait que ce soit une ressource finie intéresse beaucoup de géologues qui depuis la découverte du pétrole étudie l’épuisement de cette ressource.
L’idée qui revient souvent, c’est que l’extraction de pétrole pourrait avoir une trajectoire qui ressemble à ça.
Dans l’idée de cette courbe, le début c’est quand les gens ne savait pas trop comment en extraire et à quoi ça sert,
à partir de là, on creuse pétrole, on rêve pétrole, on mange pétrole puis arrive le pic,
après ce point, il devient de plus en plus difficile d’en extraire, il faut creuser plus profond, plus dur, plus loin,
il faut plus de moyen pour moins de pétrole.
Mais cette courbe… c’est un modèle, une prédiction,
il est difficile de savoir à quoi s’attendre exactement, la courbe peut être plus haute, plus basse, avoir des bosses,
et puis quand est-ce que le pic va avoir lieu ?
Celle-ci à été tracée par le géologue Marion Hubbert en 1974,
elle prévoit un pic d’extraction mondial entre 1991 et 2000.
Ce pic n’est pas arrivé,
comme on le voit en regardant ce qui a effectivement été extrait.
Alors ça à été mis à jour, y compris par deux géologues en 1998 dans “La fin du pétrole bon marché”.
Leurs prédictions voulaient que le pic de production ait lieu en 2004.
Ce qui n’est pas arrivé… non plus.  Et il y a eu des dizaines d’autres prédictions dans tous les sens.
Toutes ces erreurs n'invalident pas forcément l’idée du pic de production de pétrole, ça montre surtout que la prédiction c’est compliqué.
En plus d'essayer de prévoir le futur, il faut aussi prévoir les comportements humains de ce futur.
Parfois les prédictions de courbe fonctionne plutôt bien.
Une des courbes proposée par Hubert en 1956 pour l’extraction de pétrole aux État-unis
prédit correctement un pic d’extraction dans les années 70 et même le rythme de la chute de production.
Mais ce que n’avait pas pu prévoir Hubert ce sont les nouvelles techniques d’extractions qui vont complètement changer
ce qu’il est possible de sortir du sol.
Le pétrole est très léger, il a tendance à s’échapper de la roche qui l’a vu naître, la roche-mère.
Il migre en surface et il peut être retenu par une couche de roches imperméable, comme des argiles ou du sel.
Donc contrairement à ce qu’on peut imaginer, le pétrole ne forme pas du tout des lacs souterrains d’or noir.
C’est un liquide qui imbibe des roches poreuses, un peu comme des éponges imprégnées d’un jus poisseux et nauséabond.
Mais si on a bien repéré notre endroit et qu’on y creuse, avec un peu de chance du pétrole en jaillit et on devient riche, on porte des chapeaux de cow-boy et on sourit comme ça.
Enfin là, je parle du pétrole conventionnel.
Parce qu’avec la raréfaction des gisements, on s’intéresse de plus en plus au pétrole non conventionnel.
C’est en fait nos kérogènes. Vous savez, ce pré-pétrole.
On passe pas forcément par toutes les étapes “soupe de plancton pourri - pyrolyse - pétrole”.
Dans certains cas, le kérogène peut ne pas être chauffé
et rester à l’intérieur de la roche-mère.
A ce moment-là, on appelle ça des schistes ou des sables bitumineux.
C’est des roches très sombres qui fleurent bon l’essence.
Et c’est à partir de ces cailloux-là qu’on extrait les fameux gaz de schistes… mais aussi du pétrole, dit non conventionnel.
Notamment par fracturation hydraulique.
On injecte un fluide sous pression dans la roche pour la fissurer et on récupère le précieux nectar.
Puis on passe le tout au four à 500 °C (thermostat 16) pour le transformer en pétrole.
Exploiter ces hydrocarbures-là, c’est beaucoup plus difficile que de planter une paille géante dans une éponge imbibée de pétrole.
Comparées au conventionnel, ça reste des manips assez costaudes et moins rentables,
puisque les hydrocarbures sont présents en beaucoup plus petites quantités dans la roche.
Donc en gros, c’est plus difficile d’en extraire, il faut creuser plus profond, plus dur, plus loin,
il faut plus de moyen pour moins de pétrole.
Les innovations du forage et de l’extraction de pétrole ont permis d’augmenter la quantité des réserves de pétrole.
Des ressources sont devenues techniquement exploitables.
Tellement exploitable d’ailleurs qu’en 2019, les États-Unis ont extrait plus de pétrole de leur sol qu’au plus haut du pic en 1970.
Pourtant jusqu’en 2004, l’idée du pic pétrolier était sérieusement considérée et populaire, notamment aux États-Unis.
Les scénarios catastrophes ne se limitaient pas à celui d’un réchauffement climatique.
Une des peurs de l’époque c’était la pénurie de pétrole.
L’expression du pic pétrolier “Peak Oil” enregistrait en 2004 presque autant de recherche sur Google que l’expression “Climate Change”. (Changement climatique)
15 ans plus tard, le débat sur le pic de production de pétrole et la peur du manque de pétrole au niveau mondial peuvent surprendre.
Selon l’entreprise pétrolière BP, les réserves mondiales connues, sont de de plus de mille milliards de barils,
c’est plus de pétrole que l’humanité à extraite ces 100 dernières années.
Ce chiffre n’est pas forcément super fiable, parce que d’un côté il est difficile de savoir exactement ce que chaque pays à dans son sol,
la plupart peuvent avoir un intérêt à surestimer leur réserves.
Après de l'autre côté,
les réserves ne compte que ce qu’il est possible d’extraire avec les techniques et le prix actuel.
Beaucoup de pétrole n’est pas aujourd’hui compté comme réserve parce que trop compliquées et coûteux à extraire.
Mais avec le changement climatique causé en partie par la consommation massive de pétrole se pose une question,
y a-t-il trop de pétrole sur Terre ?
Bah je sais pas, le pétrole n'a rien demander à personne en fait. Donc, on pourrait juste ne pas aller le chercher.
Alors comment ne pas extraire la dernière goutte de pétrole ?
L’idée de ne pas tout sortir de terre se développe vraiment depuis les années 2010
quand il est devenu évident que même si le pétrole est une ressource finie,
il va falloir en finir avant la fin.
C’est l’idée des réserves fossiles non brulables.
On parle bien de réserves de pétrole parce qu’il serait possible techniquement et économiquement de les extraire,
le problème c’est de les brûler et d’émettre du CO2.
En tout cas, si le but, c’est de limiter les émissions de CO2 comme prévu par les accords du Climat de Paris.
195 pays ont déclaré que leur objectif est de limiter le réchauffement climatique à 2 degrés Celsius,
selon les chercheurs Christophe McGlade & Paul Ekins,
ça veut dire qu’il faut qu’un tiers du stock de pétrole, la moitié du stock gaz naturel et plus de 80% du charbon ne peuvent pas être brûlé.
On est là à l’opposé de l’idée du pic pétrolier. Il ne s’agit pas de subir un pic, mais de le provoquer !
L’année 2019 va peut être ressembler à un pic de consommation et d’extraction
à cause des récessions causé par la pandémie de 2020,
mais rien n’indique que cette tendance soit durable,
au contraire aucun pays ne parvient à diminuer significativement sa consommations de pétrole et d'énergie fossil,
cela demande des changements radicaux d’organisation économique.
Et ce qui est vrai pour la consommation est aussi vrai pour l’extraction qui a lieu partout dans le monde.
Aux Moyen Orients aux États-Unis, en Chine, au Brésil, en Russie.
Même au Canada ou en Norvège où les populations et le gouvernement semblent sensibles aux questions climatiques,
l’intérêt pour l’extraction de pétrole ne diminue pas.
La Norvège par exemple à connu un pic de production après avoir débuté en 2020 l’exploitation de Johan Sverdrup,
une réserve de pétrole enfouie sous la mer du nord.
Au moment où les tensions entre différentes puissances mondiales sont visibles,
que la dépendance des économies au pétrole reste vrai, il faut aujourd’hui répondre à la question brûlante
et quasiment impossible :
comment garder du pétrole dans le sol ?
Ben on creuse pas, et pis voilà
Avec Valentine, on pensait aller à Palavas-les-Flots, ça nous fera un petit voyage sympa.
Bon bah, nous on retourne à Paris.
C’est moins exotique,
je vous proposerais bien de passer mais c’est mieux si on se retrouve.
Au fond, je crois que je préfère suivre les chemins qui mènent nulle part.
Mais bon, là je vais rentrer dans l’Orne,
ça va me prendre une heure, ce sera rapide. Voilà.
Bon on fait comme on a dit, tu récupères la baraque pour la saison prochaine à Fougères.
Ok par contre, tu leur facturais combien de loyers ?
Je ne suis pas sûr de comprendre. Il y avait un contrat de bail, on divisait tout par quatre, je sais pas...
Ouais, dans ce cas-là, je vais revoir ça avec mon porte juriste, pour revoir à la hausse ou à la baisse. Un truc comme ça.